we now have video of marjorie taylor
green
this new wacky republican congresswoman
q anon congresswoman of
jewish space lasers fame there is video
of her
from a week before election day she sat
down
with a pro-gun activist named chris
door this was broadcast on facebook
from a pennsylvania gun shop and this is
a 22-minute interview
posted by the pennsylvania firearms
association
and marjorie taylor green and the gun
shop owner i'm sorry the gun activist
at the gun shop talked about the second
amendment
how important it is to back donald trump
how important it is to back other
far-right republicans
in the election and green warned
that socialists must be fended off
socialists like
joe biden who i can't imagine anything
socially i can't remember
a single socialist idea joe biden has
put forward they would take everybody's
guns and on and on
and she appeared to support political
violence
by saying you only get your freedoms
back
with the price of blood that's the key
part
and we'll look at a little bit of this
beyond that but that key part about the
price of blood is right at the beginning
but here's the deal if this generation
doesn't stand up and defend freedom it's
gone
yeah and once it's gone freedom doesn't
come back by itself
the only way you get your freedoms back
is it's it's earned with the price of
blood
we we can't be too busy or too
complacent or too worried about
offending someone
anymore it's there's no more excuses
this is this is it november 3rd
freedom is on the ballot you have a
choice of either voting
for freedom by voting for donald j trump
for president again for four more years
voting republicans straight down your
ballot or you're going to vote for
socialism
and vote to completely end america as we
know it and this is
this is no joke they do not want you to
be able to defend yourself
because if you can defend yourself guess
what then you can
stop a tyrannical government however if
they take away your guns
then you can't not only can you never
stop a tyrannical government
you can never even defend yourself if
someone is breaking in your home
and and that's the reality this is where
we are today in 2020.
so freedom comes back only
with the price of blood they
i guess democrats don't want you to be
able
to defend yourself so
supportive of violence to achieve
political goals
and then also in another uh prior clip
um on 9 911 claims there's no evidence
that a plane actually crashed into the
pentagon on 911
a uh unfortunately relatively
uh significantly repeated conspiracy
theory here is marjorie
taylor greene a literal 9 11 truther
now in the house of representatives
barack obama becomes president
in 2008 okay um by that time in our
american history
we had had george bush for eight years
we it's 9 11
sorry about that guys call came in so i
had to decline it um
but we had witnessed 9 11 right we had
witnessed 9 11.
the terrorist attack um in new york and
the plane that
uh crashed in pennsylvania and the
so-called
plane that crashed into the pentagon
it's odd there's never any evidence
shown for a plane
in the pentagon but anyways i won't i'm
not going to dive into the 911
conspiracy she won't dive into it
she'll merely mention it offhandedly oh
okay
all right this is a certifiably sick
woman
don't we need to be giving psych evals
to run for congress
don't we need to do something create
some basic
uh battery of tests for uh
establishing a fundamental basic level
of fitness to be a member of the house
of representatives or the u.s senate
but of course the problem isn't just the
candidates and i know that many of you
will often focus only on one side or the
other yes
the the fact that marjorie taylor green
is a candidate is a problem but if
nobody was willing to vote for her we
wouldn't be
needing to worry about it i've said this
about trump
if no one fell for trump if the
republican primary voters weren't wacky
enough to fall for trump
trump saying i'm running wouldn't really
matter the bigger problem
is that so many people said yes this is
who i'm choosing and i know
that there are some who will say well
it's because the democrats didn't put up
something better no no no
the democrats did the democrats may not
have put up exactly what we wanted
but the democrats put up something
better uh and uh the the problem is
really bigger than
any one thing i was thinking back
yesterday as i was
preparing the story remember when sarah
palin was the craziest person in the
republican party
things have escalated very very quickly
and
i don't know why marjorie taylor green
remains in congress even one more minute
every republican lawmaker should be put
on camera and asked
why don't these comments uh warrant
an immediate expulsion from the house of
representatives
on the bonus show today we'll be talking
about why
it's not even likely she will be a spell
expelled maybe censured
but very unlikely to be expelled more on
that
on the bonus show we'll take a quick
break and be back with much
more if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video